hi my name is Michael Snyder I'm a
professor and chair of genetics at
Stanford University and I'm also the
director for the Center for genomics and
personalized medicine at Stanford so I'd
like to tell you today about our work
for using genomics for understanding
human health and probing gross lies
medicine so i'm going to start with the
premise that all of you now and that is
if we can get out of this slide here
your health is a product of two things
one is your genome hello I'm sorry
having some technical background here
okay so once again i'm michael schneider
i'm going to tell you about our work in
the area of genomics and personalized
medicine and basically we're gonna start
with this premise on this slide that is
your health as a product of your genome
environment so the top is the genome and
the bottom is exposed and these days we
can get it the first the top part of
this that is your genome through the
advances in DNA sequencing technologies
I think many of you probably know that I
actually a lot of what I'm going to say
has really been precedented by a movie
called gotica that many who may have
seen many years ago do I get at your
genome along with the various things you
might expose to your occupations what
have you will basically determine
possible outcomes for your health state
we can now as they say get at the top
part of this your genome through the
advances in genome sequencing
technologies so starting in about
2004-2005 there's been a revolution in
DNA sequencing such that the cost of
sequencing is dropped dramatically it's
about tenfold every 15 months or so
and it might be telling off a little bit
over the last year but it is still going
down and the new technology is coming
out so that we expect prices to continue
to drop but nonetheless even today for a
research G enema costs about three
thousand dollars to sequence the human
genome and it costs much much more to
analyze it though so the sequencing is
no longer the limiting step for our
price limiting step for analyzing genome
it's really the interpretation and
that's something you'll see as we go
through today but because the cost of
genome sequencing its drop so
dramatically it's had a huge impact on
medicine and personalized health and
this next slide here actually shows a
lot of different areas in which genomics
is having an impact on medicine for
instance being used to understand and
treat certain diseases such as cancer
unsolved genetic diseases I'm going to
get into this more in a minute it's also
being used quite a bit for
pharmacogenomics these tend to be more
specific tasks that you can get you get
this out of a genome sequence and a
topic that interests us a lot and then
I'm going to spend some time it's really
where this is all going in the future
which is using genomics to him to manage
health of healthy people not just those
who already have a disease so we go to
this next slide and as I say genomics is
having an impact in certain areas want
to perhaps one of the most profound area
is in fact cancer genome sequencing so I
think most of you know that cancer is a
genetic disease both in terms of its
risk for inheritance as well as somatic
changes that occur as people to go on a
life and acquire mutations and it's
thought that there's somewhere on the
order of maybe five to twenty different
driver mutations that are responsible
for causing this cancer that number was
up in the air and it probably varies a
little bit of different cancers that
we're talking about but nonetheless or
multiple mutations that are responsible
for genetic mutations that cause a
cancer phenotype that is for cells to
grow uncontrollably and so the idea is
that one will go in and sequence genomes
vote from the cancer tissue from nor
tissue and try and find genetic changes
that are responsible for possible for
these cancer phenotypes and then ideally
you try and find changes for which that
might suggest therapeutic treatments and
sweep done this as many other groups
have for quite a bit it's probably led a
lot in part by Roberto seen from Elaine
Mardis and Rick Wilson the latter at
Washington University but we've also
done quite a bit of this and I can tell
you that in virtually every case we get
information that is useful for treating
a disease one such case is shown on this
next slide here this is actually one we
just did fairly recently this is a
patient with metastatic colon cancer so
very late stage cancer and just by
sequencing the genome one could see two
regions it jumped right out at you or
there's an amplified region for the EGF
receptor gene which is generally not
very common in colon cancer it actually
happens about two percent of the time
but because this individual had this
kind of mutation and also because our
drugs on the market for EGF receptor
there two drugs in fact already approved
for this not for colon cancer they've
member crew for other cases but it's
clear that it's an obvious candidate to
use then for therapeutic treatment of
this king individual and in fact we are
treating this individual with one of
those two drugs so the point is that
actually you can get changes suggested
that will lead to treatments and as I
say we find information that both tells
us what we probably should be treating
with as well as information that what we
might normally treatment may not be
useful so negative information is
sometimes valuable as well and all this
is happening because cancer really
different cancers have different genes
mutated in fact it's going to be common
to classified genes more by mutations
rather than their site of origin so it's
more this is a more informative to call
this patient is amplified for EGF
receptor rather than colon cancer
because that's really the relevant thing
that's going on and so um one lesson out
of all of this is that it's going to be
clear that that this is an avenue
available to people for treating this in
a for treating camps and I think all of
us expect that this will become standard
of care probably within a few years this
isn't going to be 20 years away this
will be coming in the very near future
the other area where genomics is having
enormous impact is in fact in issues of
childhood disease of Mendelian diseases
and sporadic diseases that appear and
there's been a number of cases of the
tested and a few spectacular successes
I'll tell you right off the bat most of
the time this does not work and I'll
show you some of the challenges
associated with this but I think one of
the more it spectacular cases is a case
that was done by Richard ribbed Gibbs
and Jim Lipsky at Baylor but actually
looked into a family that had this
disease here chins up at the child there
were two twins that had it turns out
gastonia they were born and from very
early stage was recognized there were
problems they the babies were a floppy
and they had various abnormalities and
they were really quite sick for all the
early years of their lives and it was
actually the mother who figured out that
the children had dystonia and they
treated the children with el dopamine
and then actually improved the health of
the children they were completely sure
but it helped them quite a bit but they
still had some problems and then many
years later at she just a few years ago
they sequenced the genome of these two
twins along with the parents and
discovered that in fact they had a
mutation in this gene with the red axe
it's called the spr gene and that gene
it turns out is involved in dopamine
biosynthesis along with another very
interesting neurotransmitter serotonin
and so what they end up doing was
administering to the children not only
dopamine which they were getting already
but also serotonin which in fact
basically as a precursor serotonin they
use which basically Sheard the remaining
symptoms and so the children are very
well managed these days and the genome
sequencing really led to a very useful
treatment
dramatically improve the health of the
children so the bottom line is this is
one of the more spectacular cases so
we've taken on I'd say about 30 of these
cases so far now we have had success i
would say in about five cases i'll just
show you one here in none of our cases
have they led the treatment yet off the
site but in one case shown here this is
a collaborative study with a variety of
investigators at Harvard and other
institutions and basically these are
individuals with a combined
immunodeficiency but this is a very
special type of combined
immunodeficiency these individuals also
have multiple tests and all the tree
shows and it's very rare disease as I
say their intestinal problems and they
also have immune problems and so we were
fortunate enough to have five different
families as well as several other
individuals that were affected by the
disease the DNA was available to us and
so we perform exome sequencing just
sequencing the genes of these
individuals the gene coding regions we
went up sequencing five affected
individuals that are the ones shown with
the black boxes or square squares or
round like round circles we also
sequence the number of unaffected
individuals because that's very
informative as well so you sequence
these family members and then you try
and find mutations that would be
consistent with individuals having the
disease so if they they're black and
there and it's a homozygous mutation
they'll have two different mutations
within the gene either different
mutations of the same mutation within
both copies of the jeans and the
unaffected would either have no
mutations or one mutation it's apparent
and so we sequenced 15 individuals five
of them were affected roughly around 100
fold coverage and what we discovered is
by comparing the results of all five
families as shown here it did take all
five families in this case we found one
gene that was mutated in each case in
the families that would
in each of the families and there were
no other variants that were there that
were consistent with the segregation
pattern and this gene then turns out to
be the TTC a seven gene and by looking
at this we saw there were a number of
different mutations in the gene that
basically very equated that would be
individual families but shown on this
slide f2 means the family individual at
three another family and basically you
can see the mutations are scattered at
different locations in the gene each of
these was predicted to be deleterious by
algorithms that tell you about the sort
of thing and the bottom line is we can
pinpoint this gene is responsible now
one thing we learned from this and that
many other cities would be carrying out
it's probably more common than not that
the mutations turn out to be what are
called compound heterozygotes where
there'll be two different mutations one
in the mother's ilio one in the father's
allele and but they're different and so
each is an activating and will disrupt
the gene function and this is very very
common in many of the families that
we've analyzed so this is one of the
five successful stories they can tell
you about as I say in this particular
case it didn't help us therapeutically
here's a case that's more of a very
common scenario where we've taken on
families that have hereditary hearing
loss to see if we can understand the
underlying genetic defects of these
individuals and there have been a lot of
genes identified in this and that's one
of the problems there's actually almost
too many genes is in fact about 64 genes
that have been identified associated
with hereditary hearing loss so far and
it's clear that we're not done yet so we
went in in sequence in this case three
different families that exome sequencing
of three different families shown here
we also sequence a lot of individuals
who had a red iteri hearing loss as well
at least as far as we can tell but we
only had one affected individual we're
just curious how many times we could
solve the problem that is understand
what the
genetic defect was by sequencing these
various families on these individuals
and to make a long story short we
actually sequence all of the family
members in each of these three families
and all of these 13 other individuals to
see what we might be able to see and I
can tell you in only in one of the three
families where were able to identify
what we think is the underlying genetic
defect this is the case of family one
where we sequencing these five
individuals there was one defect that
was consistent with the segregation
patterns that was in the my 7b gene
encoding a myosin heavy chain which is
fairly similar to another hearing loss
gene that have been identified another
myosin heavy chain so we think this is
the cause of mutation in this case in
family to which is a very typical
scenario we got a short list of several
genes that were consistent with the
segregation patterns we don't know which
ones right yet which ones wrong so we
have to sort through those candidates by
other tests and in the third family the
list is just very enormous and so we
don't know which ones are responsible
and I can tell you just getting to the
end of the story that the individual pro
bands that we sequence the individuals
in all cases was not informative for
time with the underlying genetic defect
is this is just too complex and disease
and so these are just some of the kinds
of problems you run into when you're
doing these sorts of studies and so
really to figure out the genetic disease
these are some of the things you really
have to understand one is that you're
best off fine solving the disease if
there's already another individual
browser mutation it in that same gene
and we've been now found this in several
cases where these so-called recurrent
mutations are really the best way to
pinpoint the likely gene responsible for
the phenotype see you two have to look
through many families or by looking
through the literature of the database
in some cases we've looked through blogs
actually find the recurrent mutation and
that's been very informative so there's
a lot of interest than and setting up
common databases for being able to share
the sort of information because and the
families of course are very interested
in this sort of thing
at the end of the day if you can find
someone else with the same variant at
least varying in the same gene that's
predicted to be disruptive in solve
these saw what the underlying genetic
cause maybe the other thing you can use
and we all do this we look for similar
phenotypes the mouse models there's a
lot of data out there there are other
groups that are trying to recreate the
phenotypes once you find County change
you're going to make me quickly make
mutations and model organisms like
zebrafish try and understand you get a
similar phenotype or you look for jeans
and similar biological pathways that
might be defective in individuals with
similar disease phenotypes as well and
so a classic case here is like the one I
just said with the myosin heavy chain
because they're mutations in the
cytoskeleton and other myosin heavy
chain it wasn't such a stretch at a
quick my 07 be gene was likely
responsible so there are a lot of
challenges of sorting this out this
really is the bottleneck trying to find
which one is the cause of the mutation
if you're not so lucky to have one
mutation that really stands out so those
are using genomics to try and understand
phenotypes of people who have disease
already but really where genomics is
going is this concept here the idea of
using genomics to manage health of
healthy people so imagine many of you
who are listening in on this call may
not have disease problems already but
you're kind of interested in how
genomics might be useful to you and so
the underlying question is if you were
to get your genome sequence would that
be useful to you could you learn
something about it that might help you
manage your health condition and we're
certainly believers that this is the
direction the field is going to go that
is people will get their genome sequence
use this information to be on the
lookout for diseases and such and
specifically what we would envision is
this an area where you would use
genomics if you look at the top left
we're in conjunction with your position
you would use this information looking
out down to the bottom right you use it
to predict disease risk may be done
diagnose diseases early because
be on the lookout from your genomic
information if you had a disease you'd
use genomics to monitor disease states
you can certainly use genomics to help
treat disease suggest drugs like cancer
I just mentioned and finally minimally
you should be able to use genomic to try
and understand why you have what you may
have a certain disease state and even if
you can't do anything about it it's
still very useful in many cases of
trying to understand the underlying
genetic basis of this disease so we're
very interested in enrolling this
general concept out and we didn't just
want to bring in genomics we wanted to
bring in other sorts of information
specifically we wanted to bring in other
kinds of omics information and this is
reflective of the fact that I used to
get a bit frustrated when I would go to
the doctor's office and they would draw
bought and they give you back report it
would show you about 15 different things
they measured and our lab is one of the
few labs does a lot of genomics and
other sorts of omics and I always
wondered why we weren't measuring many
many more things so we not only wanted
to bring in genomic information we
wanted to bring in other sorts of
information transcriptomics proteomics
metabolomics and other sorts of
information and so many of you may know
I was at Yale University for many years
and I moved the Stanford just very
recently and so basically when I moved
to Stanford about four years ago we set
up something we call integrative
personal omelettes profiling or ipod and
the idea is that in addition to your
genome at the top you would do all these
other arms on you on a blood test to get
a much more detailed perspective of what
was going on with your health state and
you would just do one time point you
actually roll this out over a series of
time points so that you can follow in
more detail really what was going on and
how your health state might change and
specifically just go from top to bottom
we would not only look at the genome we
will look at the epigenome in my case of
DNA methyl on the transcriptome in your
mrna your micrornas its various isoforms
and edits we look at the podium in an
air case it's really what you see using
mass spectrometry we are the aficionados
out there we use
they called TMT late link to look for
differential changes in the program we
call about 4,000 proteins this is
primarily targeted I should say a
peripheral blood monocytes so what
everything we're doing here is out of
blood components and now we're doing a
little bit with urine but mostly we're
doing out of blood components because
that conforms to the existing medical
structure than people use and medical
tests people use and so we mostly do for
example transcript them and per diem and
a lot of these things out of peripheral
blood monocyte cells but some things we
do out of platinum serum so we file the
premium by mass spectrometry we also
follow more rare things that you don't
necessarily see by mass spectrometry
follow cytokines which are very
important class of molecules involved in
mediating the immune response we also
follow metabolomic case we do untargeted
metabolomic square will basically do
mass spec profiling once again we follow
about 53 other Peaks which a thousand we
know what they are the remainder there
just speaks we don't know what they are
but thousand is still pretty good
compared to what's currently done for
blood tests we also follow auto antibody
profile which initially which is
following reactivity to 9,000 proteins
these days we file reactivity to the
whole proteome along with actually the
whole virum we get concealer reactivity
in your Syrah to all these all viral all
known viruses and all known human
proteins all on a chip based assay and
lastly most recently we've been adding
on the microbiome where we're actually
following got urine skin nasal and
tongue microbiome so five different
microbiomes where we're profiling DNA
we're going to start profiling RNA and
things as well so we're good so we're
basically following all these things and
initially we simply followed the all
these things but not the epigenome
because it's kind of expensive back then
of the microbiome and we're following
about forty thousand molecules initially
in blood these days with the epigenome
and the microbiome were literally making
billions of measurement
and I'm not quite sure how you exactly
count this in terms of its definitely
billions of measurements it's maybe not
billions of molecules but it's certainly
very large numbers until you're doing
billions of assays to really follow a
person's health state if you will and so
we initially rolled this out on me again
many of you may know the story so go out
over kind of quickly we did it because
we wouldn't have access to material and
we want to make sure we were getting
samples when people weren't feeling so
well as you'll see in a minute we also
did it because at the time genomics was
a little bit controversy a lot of people
worried that people would learn things
that they couldn't psychologically
handle like they may learned our risk
for disease and and they would be able
to handle that and so it just seemed a
lot easier to start this as a proof of
principle study with me where I didn't
have to worry about people getting upset
if anyone got upset would just be me and
that would be okay so we rolled this out
as they say on me the study really
started we had a blood sample when I
first came to Stanford for years ago and
then actually when we launched a study
was day zero you'll see that in the top
laughs and it just so happens on that
day I had a rhinovirus infection so we
took blood that day four days later if
you look to the neck next notch to the
right there and then 21 days later we
took another sample and then we
basically sample about every two to
three months when I'm healthy but it
turns out i had little kids so i pick up
virus infections quite a bit and in fact
I've now had six viral infections over
the last three years we've been
collecting samples for about three and a
half years now so nine months after my
first viral infection had a very Nancy
respiratory syncytial virus infection it
was fairly typical literally sinnis I
was feeling congested got a little sick
we took blood that day the next day
later two days later two days later
three days you can see quite a few
samplings we do then sampling when I'm
sick and then about every two to three
months when I'm healthy and as I say so
so far over the last three and a half
years it had a total of
six viral infections there are three
rhinovirus in fact you can see they're
the ones in red this RSV infection i
mentioned before now to add no virus
infections and the other thing you'll
probably notice is that I typically seem
to get sick about twice every winter and
that sounds been popping up so we
basically have as a state collected
samples from all these states and we've
been analyzing them and I'm just kind of
summarize the results because I
presented this many times and also we
have published us but I give you a few
highlights and then I want to talk about
some lessons in the future directions
and new things that we've covered as
well so we started by sequencing my
genome very deeply with several
different technologies and come back to
this in a minute but we generate a very
accurate genome sequence by using
different technologies illuminant
complete genomics one was several to
connect some sequencing technologies and
came up with a list of 3.3 million i
confident single nucleotide variants
about 200,000 insertions and deletions
that are small and then about 3,000
structural variants which are larger
deletions that they they're not as many
but they do affect a lot of nucleotides
and then what we did next was we phase
aegina now it's interesting in my case
we actually phase my genome initially by
sequencing my mother and that worked
pretty well but there's some new
technology out there that gives you
essentially long synthetic reads if you
will by molecular now part of alumina
and they basically generate roughly 10
KB reads or so and that's long enough
you can capture several variants on the
same synthetic reading lane that is a 10
KB you get on the order of 6 to 10
different variants in that segment and
that's enough than to link up the
different variants so that you can
assign the brains to one chromosome or
the other so your mother your father and
that worked really really well for us in
the end we were able to assign 98.2
percent of my variance to my moms and my
dad's chromosomes using this technology
so as I say it worked really really well
for us what we did next actually
Leon molecular technology is actually
quite new is we've analyzed the genome
for medical risk and we do two kinds of
analyses here we look for rare variants
that are likely to be highly penetrant
for causing human disease and then we
also do a more integrative analysis of
the 23 meets or where we integrate over
multiple markers for complex disease to
look at disease risk so this first slide
here that i'm showing you actually shows
a pipeline set up by you and Ashley Atul
Butte arrests Altman to look at dealing
disease or is highly penetrant diseases
and I won't have time to go through a
lot of the sudden to say that we spend
most of our time looking at the coding
snips this is a pipeline we set up and
used or early on these dates as a
slightly revised version of this but we
spend more time looking at protein
coding sequence variants that's the
pipeline on the right we do look a
little bit at the non-coding ones most
since place regions and to some extent
of micro arranged but mostly in the
splice junctions and these days we're
looking at regulatory sequences will get
to a little later on where we spend most
of our time looking protein coding
variants we resume in mostly on those
that are not synonymous meaning they
cause amino acid changes and then we
look at those that are predicted to be
damaging by various algorithms and so
the the net result is we then take those
and we zoom in on those that are
associated with human disease so there's
a database online mendelian hearings man
that has curated variants associated
with human disease and and we zoom in on
variants again that associated human
disease that are predicted to be
damaging and better rare and so I have
50 one of those as you'll notice in this
box and so going to the this next slide
this is actually the list of those rare
variants that are associated with human
disease and for the most part mine
actually looks pretty tame pretty mild I
did see mutation and polymer a scheme
that's as red box here so she would say
plastic anemia I'm going to come back to
that in a little bit and then we also
saw mutations associated with other
things I was no
going into the study that I had high
cholesterol and we think the mutations i
have in this team GC k are at the bottom
are likely to be associated and causing
that high cholesterol phenotype i have
actually have two different mutations
once again a compound heterozygote one
of my father's one damaging mutation my
father's allele one of my mother's a
wheel that are probably responsible for
my high cholesterol I'm great responded
a statin so we've got that under control
and then actually not indicated here but
to the right to the left of that GC KRG
and are two other genes kcg an 11 and
gel up for they're actually associated
with type 2 diabetes we did notice
thumbs through this analysis are not
rare alleles that we because these are
common disease we did keep an eye on
those as I say the other thing we did
was we looked at we a more complex
disease analysis and this is where you
integrate over multiple markers and a
toll beautifu semble a pretty amazing
database called very mad that actions
collected a lot of information from the
literature and they've calculated
likelihoods from all these genetic
association studies and then they
integrate over the various risk and
protective alleles to predict your
whether your increased risk of decreased
rates for hundreds of disease the slide
just shows a few of those maybe
something like 10 or so different
diseases but they've actually looked
through with hundreds of diseases and
basically to walk you through this slide
as a european now i'm at the triangle is
my starting point for being at risk for
one of these diseases and on the right
is one hundred percent chance of getting
the disease and on the left was a 0%
chance the orange bar means my increased
risk amount for one of these diseases
and the blue bar means by decrease the
risk risk amount and the net result is
that for the most part when we looked at
this they called us a risk a gram most
things made sense with my family history
so for example at the bottom on a
decreased risk reside for obesity
because and that made sense nobody my
family going back to my
great-grandparents has ever been
overweight as far as I can tell
also if you look at other things like
increased coronary artery disease bars
actually a little bit further works here
but it's a that made sense sue because
everybody on my father's side is died of
heart disease you can see the increased
lipids and cholesterol and two different
places here so I am it and that made
sense with my high cholesterol so all of
that made sense from my family history
but there were some surprises too in
particular what is a man increased risk
for basal cell carcinoma that was
something came up fairly relatively
recently and I didn't know that running
in my family but ironically I didn't
happen to talk to some amount of family
members I had three sisters and two
brothers and actually discusses one
sister and two brothers and it turns out
they've each had multiple lesions of
basal cell carcinoma so in fact this is
in my family history just didn't know it
so one of the arguments I like to make
is that you're actually your genome is a
better indicator of your family history
than your family is because your family
doesn't always discuss these things in
the open and i'll let you have access to
every tease health records you may not
know what's exactly in your family
history so as I say basal cell
carcinomas just not something we ever
talked about at the dinner table so it
really never came up now one thing that
came up very early in the study is
obviously this thing with the big era
where I was shown to be at increased
risk for type 2 diabetes where I went
from something like a twenty-five
percent chance of forty seven percent
chance of getting type 2 diabetes that
was also surprised not so evident from
my family history and so we did look at
this further now remember we've been
doing all this other omics profiling so
we were following my glucose we're doing
standard medical tests as well follow my
glucose originally everything else you
can imagine over these last three and a
half years and this just shows you some
of the information from the glucose art
and what you'll notice is if you look on
the left my glucose is marching along
just fine weather didn't matter whether
it's fasting or not they were always
pretty much in the normal range or
typically 90 when I'm fasting or maybe
up to
Angela not but it was nothing to be
concerned about but ironically right
around that day 320 or so it was a day I
went in for a glucose metabolism test
and I went to get this test because my
genome basically suggested us at risk
for diabetes and one would see how my
metabolism went and so when we so what
even before we started to test they
measure my glucose and you'll notice
that's the one at that inflection point
my glucose was 127 which is high that's
not normal for passing route house and
we were both surprised as we repeated
the test and sure enough it came out the
same number went on in my leg group
glucose metabolism seemed okay but
obviously because it's high we did a lot
of follow-up tests and you'll notice if
you going to the right week later my
glucose increased about 141 or so we
also measured hemoglobin a1c which came
out actually quite high six point four
percent which is quite high diabetes is
typically classified of 6.5 so it's
right on the edge and then about four
weeks later I went to my general
practitioner would also who also made
all the measurements and and then did
the hemoglobin a1c and glucose and came
out even higher SAT glucose was 150 then
hemoglobin a1c at 6.7 and and so the net
result was that was pretty clear that
after a period of time my glucose and
hemoglobin a1cs were high and in fact I
was classified as diabetic so they can
tell you when that was that was april
eleventh of 2011 it's just after that
six point seven is when I got the news
back and and at that point I decided I
had to do something that's clearly
prolonged up there for a time what's in
a few days if I didn't already been a
few months and so basically I completely
changed my diet I pretty much had the
worlds where it's diet meaning I ate a
lot of desserts and things pretty much
every night and I just essentially cut
all that out as of april eleventh two
thousand except for one by the wedding
cake i've had summer of that year
otherwise i really don't touch that
anymore and i also increased my exercise
and it didn't happen right away you can
see as you look
right but gradually my glucose came down
to normal on for the most part it stayed
down ever since and I've been measuring
is to say for three and a half years
those bar keeps going to the right
bounce around a little bit last winter
with some of the loyal type see
generally say pretty low so the bottom
line is that my genome predicted odds at
risk for disease which in fact i did get
and so this is really the first time
genomics have been used to do that but
because i did in fact follow this
because at my gym sequence i could catch
it early and it's able to manage the
disease which is nice the other thing
you'll notice is that this all appeared
after this very nasty respiratory
syncytial virus infection which is very
unusual amongst adults it's quite common
in kids but not that common on adults
and i was actually out for several days
as you know it's quite sick and and it's
clear that that's when my glucose fight
just after that and so our hypothesis is
that my genome has me at risk for
diabetes the genetic risk alleles i have
and that in conjunction with this
environmental stimulus the RSV infection
is what's triggered the disease now we
can't prove that but it certainly leads
a very strong hypothesis that you can
follow up with other acids and enjoy
i've gotten lots and lots of requests
and comments from various people above
actually had similar experience so
anecdotally i can tell you this is
happening quite a bit and that kind of
connection have never been made before
for type 2 diabetes which is a form i
have as we made for type 1 but not for
type 2 diabetes okay so the other thing
i can tell you is that we've been
measuring all kinds of things cytokines
the transcriptome korea metabolomic I'm
to go into this but the bottom line is
you can follow all of these molecules
and pathways changing in a level no
one's ever seen before and many of these
are very relevant to either a viral
infection during the time i get sick or
in the case during the time i got
diabetes you will in fact see very
interesting pathways changing during
those time this is just one example on
this slide here where we solve spikes of
activity that occurred about two weeks
after I got the RSV infection
this is an integrative analysis of
transcript temperament ablum to quite a
bit of a computational expertise to be
able to systematically co-op the pathway
to change as you go through these
various disease periods and we had a
physicist George me as we figured this
out and set up a nice framework and i
forgot to say that we reach and it's one
spearheads of the study i mention all
the people can but the bottom line is
you can do things like this you'll see
this giant spike if you look at the top
panel that red bar that's there those
are all the molecules that are going up
at this two-week period and all kinds of
interesting changes are occurring these
places I'm changed but one of the
biggest pathways that goes up is in fact
glucose regulation of insulin secretion
actions increase during this period and
that is primarily a proteomic signature
the yellow dots if you look to the right
the components that are changing those
in primarily proteomics and then there
are other things that go down during
that period there's all kinds of
signaling pathways that change
interestingly my platelets are actually
put my platelet plug formation pathways
going down and this is actually mixed
responsible transcript on that podium
you actually see some interesting
metabolites change to an echo stannum
and why is this interesting well this is
the power of integrative omics profiling
because what you can do is you can see
all kinds of pathways change at a level
you wouldn't see if you only followed 1
ohm these mixed signals will only that
they will reveal pathways that appear
again that you wouldn't necessarily
follow had you only follow the single
transcriptome you would have missed both
of these if you only pound followed
transcriptome by doing the per diem and
you can follow other pathways to change
and you need for some case you need at
all to see the various pathways that are
changing and it's really been incredibly
informative Duvall goes so we're big
believer is that the future is going to
be here that is that you know in my
world I think I would be an advocate for
people getting their genome sequence at
birth or quite frankly before birth with
the technology thing where they are
these days we would also then combine
other omics information
and use that actually when you're
getting your various help you know task
me go doctor we would follow things in a
much more detailed level than we're
currently doing i'm not saying you'd
follow billions of things and the moment
clinical tests but you'll be following
many many more things that we're
currently doing we also bring on the
other information also get through in a
minute you use this information to
predict disease risk diagnose disease
early and modern treat disease own
things i said earlier now i will tell
you i don't think that everyone
necessarily needs access to the genome
sequence it should be up to them to
decide if they want that information but
i do think that some of the information
is valuable and could be relayed back
you can write a birth much like PKU is
relayed back at birth and other
information would be available as you
needed it if symptoms arise or if you
saw you're at risk for certain things
you could actually use that information
that train keep an early look out for
that or even adjust your lifestyle and
in a real and ideally you'd like to be
able to get this information predicted
but your risk for a leg Annika and then
monitor your activities so that you
don't put yourself at risk for those
sorts of things so that's the world that
I would like to see in the future now
just to bring up a few things people say
well Mike if you do these tests you're
going to wind up saying you know if
everybody gets a genome sequence you may
wind up saying there lots of disease
variance is going to cost hundreds of
thousands of dollars and get all this
information they can't use it's little
things a mess and there there's honey
reasons why you shouldn't do this and so
I'm working with you and Ashley and Tom
cute airmass a group of us Rick doing
Megan Grove and creeping on in
particular actually just went out and
tested that assumption of people are
making and we asked if you sequence the
genomes of healthy people how often will
you find information that would be
abused of person that would go back to
them and how much would it cost and what
kinds of information might you learn
from healthy people's genomes and so
what we did was we sequence five asians
and five europeans and basically look
through their genomes and looked at what
kinds of reportable
disease risks information might be there
there's been some guidelines set up by
the American College of medical genetics
that basically has 57 well sigh
identified that they suggest you report
information back to patients on and so
we looked at those 57 low sign it turns
out from our small study which is 10
people or we looked at their very
attention and exquisite detail so it's
more than 57 losa but even from the 57
low side we found a median of five
reportable disease risk associations
including one individual who had a
bracket mutation do not have a family
history so we would argue that's useful
information and their age you can see
ears to the settings from these five
reportable disease risks has led the
three follow-up diagnostic tests and the
cost is somewhere on the order you can
see here about four hundred to fourteen
hundred dollars so you know not dirt
cheap but not super expensive either so
somewhere in a reasonable range and what
would argue that this actually could
save a lot of money in the long run so
the bottom line is this is very doable
you do get some useful information from
virtually every information personally
we sequenced and in some cases that we
would argue it's extremely valuable now
it's not simple to do this it takes
about 54 minutes we're burying it and if
most individuals have somewhere on the
order of 50 to 100 different variants
that you look up it does take quite a
bit of time we spend about 40 hours per
genome you go through all the ranks not
just the 50 70 site so it is quite a bit
of effort to do this so so that part is
up there but nonetheless we would argue
this is the kind of information like
we're in by sequencing a normal person
genome okay now I won't tell you this is
all piece of cake there are a lot of
challenges associated with this I've
listed a few here you see the numbering
got a little bit screwed up but the
these are just some of the issues we
it's a smallest smallish list or many
more challenges here these are just some
of the things and I thought I would go
through a few of them personal genome
sequencing accuracy and coverage is
still a big issue make people don't
realize this but getting your sequence
doesn't mean you get a nice perfect
genome sequence and we knew this early
on when we sequenced my genome with
complete genomics and alumina and only
eighty-nine percent of the single
nucleotide variants overlap
two technologies both work pretty well
and we can validate a lot of parents
with both the common variants are always
right and the platform specific range
for complete genomics aluminum our offer
right there not always right but one
platform often this is another one finds
and these are off a very interesting
variants you're some of the validation
data on this slide so you can pour
through these and and get a sense of
what the accuracy is and I can also tell
you that a lot of these variants are
very interesting some of them have been
associated with human disease so you do
want to collect the information from a
lot of these low side and this is just
single nucleotide variants for the in
dells it's even worse we only count
twenty percent overlap of this and so
there's clearly a lot of issues with
accuracy and it has improved even since
it's for a study but there's still a
long ways to go to get perfect genomes
this is actually just highlights the
result most recently this is from a
company I'm affiliated with personalis
but they actually sequence of genome
with the exact same da but did it twice
and fairly deep the 60 X and what you'll
discover is that persol there's pretty
good concordance of raw where they do
agree but you'll discover that one run
will find things the other one run well
fine so for example run to found 2.4% a
few on the right of variants that we're
not family run one and vice versa some
variants per pound with run one at work
out with one two or three point seven
percent and so there is a coverage issue
this and this is fairly recent so this
is relatively latest technology for
sequencing again it's pretty deep it's
deeper than most people get their genome
sequence which is more like 35 x so the
reason for this is that some regions of
the genome I've covered very well for
all kinds of reasons there's all kinds
of errors that show up and the genome
sequences and so it's really important
to understand where they are and where
they come it's also important to
increase coverage in these problematic
regions and i can tell you i'm going to
skip over this next cycle are getting a
little late but with if you do exome
sequencing or whole genome sequencing
you will be missing a lot of useful
information and once again here's
from personalis there's about six
thousand medically useful genes in the
human genome a normal exome only covers
two thousand of them to ninety-nine
percent coverage at twenty fold coverage
and so you're missing for most genes
there's a there's a blind spot if you
will and in the exome sequence and most
people don't realize that but it's true
for most so it's true for two-thirds of
the genes and you can design custom
exomes in this is what my company is
done so again I am bias here but you can
design exomes the back fill these region
and cover them more accurately and let's
next slide I want up time to but it goes
over this in more detail the blue is a
region covered if you look at these
various breeds and blue is what gets
covered by a normal exome Green is what
you can fill in if you design a
specialized like some chip and it
actually just the technology's a little
bit so you can capture these regions but
you do need specialized methods for
doing so because of the some of the
problems that are there all right I see
I'm running out of time so I'm going to
wrap this up there also issues with
genome interpretation I mentioned this
telomerase allele I had this mutation in
turret and actually predicted I should
have aplastic anemia which I don't and
so we think this mutation is probably
contextual but then some people causes
aplastic anemia now there's a dozen so
there are kinds of issues like that that
you have to deal with it there are other
issues like most variants that probably
associated with disease don't lie in
coding regions and so we and other
groups are working very hard texture now
incorporate these into genome annotation
again because it's late I won't go into
this but we the top line shows
incorporating mutations and protein
coding genes in the genome annotation
the bottom is the non-coding part we
looked at if you look in the middle we
zoom in on those variants that affect
transcription factor binding and there
are many many more than no matter how
you slice or dice there are ten times
more variant associative alleles that
are problematic that are affecting
regulatory sequence and there are
damaging wheels for protein coding
sequence and so we think you really
you get them incorporated and in fact
there are many cases where you'll have
jeans with the mutation and here's one
example down below where you have one
new teacher in a coding region gene and
the other mutation will be in a
regulatory sequence and so if you only
looked at coding you would miss that you
would think well they're heterozygous
that's okay but it turns out at least in
this genome the person actually has two
different mutations that should both be
crippling and you want to collect that
information we're also bringing in other
sorts of information like menthol um and
lastly I would say we want to bring in
other types of information as well we're
measuring all kinds of activities to
bring in so we can start bringing the
exposé on better in this case I would
call it the activity on my guess where
you're following your walking and
cycling and all kinds of things and I'm
all wired for these things as are other
people are doing quantified self
measurements as well people like very
smart and others and we're actually
bringing us and the goal is to integrate
this information with Alex profiling so
it's gotten a little late so I'll just
wrap this up a personal genome
sequencing is here you think it's not
only sequencing you should bring in
other omics information and you can get
a much more detailed perspective of
what's going on with the health state
and one of the important things I want
to leave is this one down here number
five which is every person disease
profile is different this is the power
of personalized medicine and what we
really want to be able to do is follow
for every individual there changes that
occur so you can actually see them early
for that individual not just what it
means on average but for that individual
when their health state changes you want
to catch it and basically prescribe
appropriate treatment and the other
thing I'll tell you is because the
information is getting some so complex I
think you're going to be responsible for
your own health and I think this is an
important lesson all of us should should
take so here is the data any of the data
we publish you can find it this website
up listed at the bottom and lastly
there's a lot of people have contribute
this work I won't have time to go
through them all but it's really
spearheaded by riri-chan Georgiana
Sugarland Jennifer Connelly was young
lots of wonderful collaborators it may
different levels and I do like to thank
my mom was a great sport in many parts
of the study sub
I want to thank her and I'll open this
up to questions now so same time for a
little bit of time for questions so you
have any okay okay so I see there are a
number of questions here a lot are in
the area of cost what does it cost to do
this so let me say it at the moment that
this is very much a research study we're
trying to collect as much information as
possible and where we're going as deep
as possible to really click very
detailed information and without the
microbiome and without the DNA methyl um
the cost for a light version of this is
probably a few thousand dollars i'd say
on the order of about twenty-five
hundred dollars or so now with the
methylome at the way we do it and some
of the other technologies microbiome
then adds more cost on but we're doing
it fairly deep because we're trying to
collect all kinds of information like
allele-specific expression so it could
be done to a certain level i should say
that's just the raw cost of doing it the
analysis is incredibly expensive because
we're still working out algorithms and
ways to do this as well but i think a
lite version of this could roll out for
a few thousand dollars or possibly the
last actually probably 45 no dollars in
the not so distant future but right now
we're doing it at the very deluxe detail
so we can again get as much information
because the ultimate clinical tests i
think isn't going to be billions of
measurement so it's probably going to be
a few thousand few hundred a few
thousand measurements and that will
become much more affordable and
targetable so we just have to know what
those few thousand things we want to
study are we don't know that yet until
we do more people and more of these
studies and i forgot to say we are
rowing this out 250 pre-diabetics now
and other individuals as you might guess
okay so that's a few let's see that's
one of the questions so someone asks
what's the current status of gene
profiling patients at risk for
progressive kidney disease patients with
type 2 diabetes and others and as I say
work there's a lot of people doing
transcriptomic studies and with these
because that's a very mature technology
the integrative onyx profiling
only rolling out whereas I say we're
rolling out for type 2 diabetes we're
doing 50 pre-diabetics people arrested I
take your diabetes and we hope their
role in other people we are doing some
people with kidney transplants and
things as well so we're just starting
some of that so we have there are many
more studies to do and it does take
quite a bit to do one of these studies
they're very you have to set an
infrastructure in place actually done
that part i forgot to say that cause
millions set up the infrastructure
initially but now to execute from that
infrastructure it's not as bad so i
think it will roll into these other
areas it'll just take a little bit of a
time as we move forward and i know lots
of other people we've been teaching how
to do this it's an interesting question
someone asked what is the average data
side how many gigabytes well it's
interesting you should say that it's
actually leaving out the first 14 time
points we did we're 50 terabytes of data
we collected on me with the genome
sequence and the transcriptome because
we're doing very deep analysis and
premium as well can get pretty deep so
we think now with the microbiome and
other parts we're collecting about six
terabytes currently on every single
sample in that range about six terabytes
and then the genome sequence is another
termite on top of that we don't do that
every time with the methylome and with
the microbiome and such it's about six
terrible terrible eight so that's a lot
so you can see you've heard about Big
Data probably many of you and this is
the ultimate Big Data this is literally
going to be well they're bigger data is
for astronomy but for a biology this is
quite huge this will turn out you can
see for me it's going to be pretty
quickly we'll have a petabyte of data
imagine doing this for a million people
which is what I'd like to see happen
that's a million petabytes of data that
gets way out there so luckily there are
getting to be better better ways of
clicking and storing large data but we
sell a lot of challenges there to go and
it's not cheap to store and manage all
that data
someone asked what's it cost for anyone
with all i'll mix interpretations and
that's a difficult one till we do all
the analyses and things the final cut
that gives back to the cost one again so
the actual data is probably a 2500 with
the microbiome things it is higher it's
probably fifteen thousand fifteen enough
one like my own but then the analysis on
top of that it does get up there so I
don't have a definitive number but as
he's turned into more routine algorithms
to get cheaper now this one is a very
interesting question how do we take into
account the impact of epigenetic
regulation and went barrington a
non-coding region so I mentioned before
the issue about non-coding region
variants that hit regulatory sequences
that we can now identify and so we've
been bringing in encode and other sorts
of data to be able to interpret the
regulatory sequence but this epigenome
question is incredibly interesting
because we think that's a big part again
number the very first slide that your
your health is a product of your genome
and your expose them and your epigenome
may be a reflecting the exposé on the
state but so we've been bringing the DNA
methyl ohm in as well and I can tell you
that's incredibly fascinating we have a
case on one of my alleles where one
allele is mutated by my mind mutations
you know typical way that's my father's
only on a particular gene involved in
thyroid function and interesting in my
mom's allele is actually shut off by
gaining methylation as far as we can
tell so that's a complex gene
inactivation situation that you would
only decipher if you have both types of
information so we're big believers
collecting the the epigenome is going to
be very very important now an idea where
would you collect it for different
tissues but we'll just have to collect
it where we can and we can collect it
off your IPS cells and things that don't
forget you can now make IPS cells of
yourself and we've done that for me that
you can do experiments on and see what's
going to happen and so we think between
the transcriptome and the proteome and
the epigenome we hope to capture some of
that expose them and form a
even if we don't know the exact exposure
one was hit with so we think that's a
certain way way to go for this in the
future is this technology ready for
massa application like 23 me and and the
answer is no not yet it does require a
lot of infrastructure and just as an
amusement aside we actually did 23andme
after we sequenced my genome and I was
pretty amazed about two-thirds of the
predictions did line up between what 23
meet predicted and what our June my
genome predicted a toll booths group
predicted from that and it was
quantitatively the numbers weren't the
same but the general concept an idea
went the same promote two-thirds of
genes that were some things that we had
found the 23 me yes but when you think
there are tests of ninety nine dollars
when I was caused several thousand
that's a significant difference let's
see what else we have here let's see
when do you think the next cost step
will be and you can't read the rest this
for for genome sequencing and yeah this
person saying it splat telling it is
seen it's a little bit plat telling you
I think it's so dropping in price and if
so does the next competitive technology
comes out there it'll drop a quite a bit
there are some coming down the road so I
predict probably by 2014 you'll see
another reasonable drop again that that
is a guest I'll homie to it there are
some very interesting technologies
coming up and I think you will see the
prices of sequence and dropping even
further there's a goal to hit a
thousand-dollar genome and in terms of
sequencing again not interpretation that
still cost us about fifteen thousand
dollars to it to do interpretation the
way we do interpretation that is looking
up all your bearings so I'm guessing a
thousand-dollar genome could get the end
of this year the beginning next year
that that's a guess that's probably not
getting too far off and let's see what
else we have here how would you expand
the technologies and for the autumn
antibody and the type of significant
results obtained that I think that's a
very interesting question
so for the auto antibodies stuff we've
been working with a company nimble
Jamaican action now display all the
human peptides and so that's how we're
now doing we're getting better coverage
although its complementary to what we
get with the length technology proto
raise that's how I didn't get into the
auto antibody program but it's very
fascinating we have cases where we can
see the immune system reacting with
antigens and we think that is reflective
of disease states and the nice thing
about having your home by Rome down on
the chip is that you can see the viral
probings that appear and the sorts of
reactivity you you can see so yeah I'm
so I think they're the auto antibody
stuff's going to be incredibly
fascinating definitely want to bring us
in to the analysis some brought up the
issue about privacy and data security
and brought in National Security Agency
and I guess these are concerns you know
I think some people are very worried
about it some people like me aren't
you're in principle you're not supposed
to be discriminated against by either
for employment or for health benefits
but you still can be discriminated
against for life insurance or for long
term disability and let's certainly like
to see the ladder go away but um I think
you know I don't know what to say about
the NSA part but I would argue that the
benefits of having your genome sequence
i think in catching disease early
outweighs that concerns about security
and people biasing against you privacy
is is an issue you can figure out
someone's identity with reasonable
probability with the genome sequences
more more people like me put all their
information out there it'll get easier
and easier to link people to their DNA
through these public databases and
there's some interesting studies on that
already so um but I would argue the
benefits of this are so very very high
and it's a nice to catch this
information for her benefit and I think
if we had a more protected environment
for long term disability than I think
some of those concerns would go away I
guess I'm not terribly worried about the
National Security Agency myself on this
but maybe others are no someone asked
what our IPS cells and I forgot these
are essentially stem cells you can make
up here yourself you can take your skin
it makes something called fibroblasts
where or your blood and you can actually
turn them into immortalized cells and in
fact those cells and basically stem
cells and you can grow them in a petri
dish and you can differentiate them in
the cardiac cells meaning your heart
cells or nerve cells and various things
and so you can do analyses on these and
they're very very valuable cells people
someday would like to use these for gene
therapy and they're already trials in
place to do this for four people at
certain diseases they think stem cells
will be very very valuable and I
envision a world where most people will
have stem cells of themselves for
nothing else than to measure the drug
responses and things so they know what
responsibilities at just from the the
cells of themselves I'm not really into
you know cloning oneself is a whole
different ball game that I don't think
we're going to be heading down in the
near future so that i don't feel have so
i think at this point you should wrap it
up i'm getting the signal to do so so
it's been great chatting online with all
of you if you have further questions
don't hesitate to email me you can find
me by just searching Schneider and
Stanford you'll find it so it's been a
lot of fun for me and I hope you enjoyed
it as well thanks very much for having
me here
you